it's hard changing your life
it was hard when just over three years
ago
in the penobscot building in detroit
michigan
where i was operating my business and i
fell on some hard times
and i was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said excuse me mr brown can
we see you for a moment
and i said yes and i walked up to the
counter and he gave me an envelope
and he said would you mind reading it
here and i opened the envelope
and the envelope was from management
that says this
is an office tower it's not a hotel
please do not sleep in your office
and i said excuse me sir i said i just
work long hours
in creating my business i'm an
entrepreneur
and right now things are bad for me but
they're not going to be
this way always
and i just asked for the opportunity to
continue to operate
like i'm doing i'm not trying to make
this my home
and it was hard coming through the lobby
and sometimes they would laugh there's a
guy talking about becoming successful
and look at him he's bathing in the
bathroom upstairs
on the 21st floor he sleeps on the floor
him and two other dreamers up there look
at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people
and i was facing financial difficulties
in my own life
i was behind on my bills and my dreams
and i'm saying to them
you can live your dream it was hard
ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing
that i could do it there were times that
i doubted myself
i said god why why is this happening to
me
i'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother i'm not trying to
steal a rod from anybody
how did this have to happen to me
it was very hard and here's what i want
to say to you
for those of you that have experienced
some hardships
don't give up on your dream no one could
have convinced me by holding on
by continuing to push forward by
continuing to run toward my dream
that one day i would have my own
talk show it's a long shot ladies and
gentlemen from liberty city an abandoned
building on a floor
never knowing my mother or father it's a
long shot
being here with you today in this dome
in atlanta it's a long shot no college
training labeled educable mentally
[ __ ]
but i kept running toward my dreams
don't stop
don't stop
don't stop running towards your dream
[Applause]
it's very important as you hold on to
that dream
there are moments when you're going to
doubt yourself
their rough times are going to come but
they have not come to stay
they have come to pass it's very
important for you to know that
don't say i'm having a bad day say i'm
having a character building day
[Applause]
it's very important for you to believe
that you are the one to make this happen
i remember
this high school teacher mr leroy
washington
at the end of school one june it was
just a few days before we were supposed
to leave
and i just got my report card
and it indicated that i'd failed history
and i'd fail english
and i would have to go to summer school
and i was feeling within myself
that i was a failure that i i'm slower
than most people
and getting paperwork and and i was
feeling down on myself and
and and very negative and mr washington
was giving a speech to the graduating
seniors and i was in 11th grade
and even though i wasn't supposed to be
in there i went in there because
the speech he was giving that speech
was for me and as he talked my heart
began to beat fast
tears began to run behind my eyes and i
was in the back just listening to him
because he said and he was a very
dramatic man
i still talk to him to this day he said
as graduating seniors of booker t
washington high school i want you to
know that you're blessed
and highly favored and that as you go
toward the future
begin to know that you have greatness
within you
and if just one of you here begin to
envision yourselves as being blessed and
highly favored
to reach your goals if just one of you
capture the essence of what that means
that you have greatness within you
and responsibility to manifest that
greatness
that you can make your parents proud you
can make your school proud
you can touch millions of people's lives
and the world will never be the same
again
because you came this way and the
students gave him a rousing
standing ovation and as he left the
auditorium i ran down the steps and i
caught him in the parking lot
i said mr washington he said yes i said
do you remember me sir
he said no i said um my name is leslie
brown my mother
she works in the cafeteria here i'm
running a twins leslie wesley
i said mr washington but you know you
know i got these big dreams you know i
like talking to people i love people i
said i want to work with people and i
got this dream of buying my mama home
could could i do that mr washington he
said it's possible mr brown
and as he walked away i called him again
i said mr washington
he said what do you want now
i said um
i'm the one sir i said
i'm the one you you remember me sir i'm
miss mamie brown's boy
i'm the word
i'm the one
and you must feel that
[Applause]
that's why you're here because you are
the one
and i remember when pbs first played one
of my specials
called you deserve one sunday afternoon
in miami florida
i had some friends call him to tell him
to tune in
and he watched the program he called me
in detroit and i answered the phone i
said hello he
said may i speak to les brown please i
said who's calling
he said you know who this is
i said oh mr washington it's you he said
you were the one weren't you i said yes
sir
he said and you were so crazy i said i
know but i'm rich now
ladies and gentlemen it's not going to
be easy
it was hard laying on the floor of the
penobscot building
looking out of the window daydreaming
saying les
can you do this can you make this
happen i used to listen to tapes day in
and day out
about see you at the top my my great
friend zig
and and dennis waitland different other
motivational speakers and dr norman
vincent peale
and dexter saying don't let nobody steal
your dream i used to ask myself
can i do this and something said within
me
you're the one you're the one
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen
while you're here and before you go back
home to your respective cities
and communities write down at least five
reasons
on why you deserve your dream and why
you won't give up
what's going to make you unstoppable why
you must be unreasonable because logical
practical thinking says
you can't do it today but if you want to
produce
unreasonable results in your life like
living your dreaming taking charge of
your destiny you've got to be
an unreasonable person you've got to be
an uncommon person so write down the
reasons of why you're here
my first major goal was to buy my mother
a home
and let me tell you something ladies and
gentlemen what what will reasons do less
nietzsche said if you know the wife for
doing you can endure almost
anyhow what do you mean by that if you
know why you're doing something
when the hard times come and they're
going to come when the disappointments
and the rejections come and they're
going to come by the truckloads
your reasons will be your rod and staff
to comfort you
to pick you up once again i got a saying
on one of my tapes if life knocks you
down
try and land on your back because if you
can look up you can get up
let your reasons get you back up
i remember when i i bought the home from
my mother and she came
out of the car when i opened the door i
said mom i think i know these people in
this house
that was my first major goal and then i
couldn't conceal it anymore i said mom i
got this for you
and as she went from room to room
looking at the house and saying thank
you jesus
thank you lord no one ever could have
convinced me that this could have
happened to me
and she looked at me she said leslie and
you cost me so much problems as a boy
you were always
into stuff she said no one could have
convinced me that day when i walked in
that house
and this lady was holding you and your
brother and she said ma'am i want you to
promise me two things and she'd say what
is it
she says juan promise me that you won't
separate them
she said i want them raised together i
want them to know each other
i got pregnant while my husband was away
in the war
and i can't keep them promise me
that you won't separate her she said i
promise i would i've never had children
i promise i won't separate him and she
said promise me
that you'll never tell him about who i
am because if
my husband ever found out he would kill
me she said i promise
and she said that she gave them to us
and and she kind of cried and
she was walking out the door and she
looked at my adopted mother she said
remember don't you separate them
she said i swear to god i won't i won't
separate them i'll keep them together
and she said as i held you all in my
arms i never had any children my arm
i didn't know how i was going to do it
but i knew with the help of god
i will do it and ladies and gentlemen
my mother had a dream of having children
and raising us she didn't know how she's
going to do it
you're going to be just like that and
some of you are already there
well you don't know how you're going to
make this happen
but you just feel within yourself some
way
somehow with the help of god i'm going
to make it happen
repeat after me please no matter how bad
it is
or how bad it gets
i'm going to make it
i'm going to make it
shake somebody's hand on your right and
left and say you got the right stuff
so yes it's possible for you to live
your dream
it's necessary that you associate with
winners
that you work your system that you are
relentless that you never give up
it's you you've got to take personal
responsibility you've got to make it
your personal business
to make it happen and you've got to
resolve within yourself
that i can do this that it's hard
but you've got to say i'm the one
i'm the one to make this happen i'm the
one to become successful in this
business
as you work to help other people to
become successful that feeds
your success but you know it's going to
be hard
but find out what will make it worth it
for you if you want to change your life
in 30 days for free check out the
program
right here below me or if you want even
more less brown motivation check out the
video right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy them
continue to believe and i'll see you
there